[Music]  harmony announces its first performance  without kamila Kibeho  we're super stoked Ally Dina Lauren and  normanni will kick off their 2017 by  taking the stage at the People's Choice  Awards on January 18th in Los Angeles  the girls are also nominated for  favorite group at the awards show the  band also announced they'll begin  recording new music this year all this  news comes after Kamiya's dramatic exit  from fifth harmony last month that led  to a whole lot of back-and-forth  obviously any band any group someday is  not going to be together anymore like  that's just you know that's just right  yeah that's the life that's just you  know the truth I think anybody kind of  knows that whether you say it or not  [Music]  you